a sense of unease and uncertainty in
burkina faso's capital wagadugu at the
market taylor suleiman kompaure is
worried burkina faso has a checkered
past with a series of military coups
since independence in
he fears the latest military takeover
may so disunity
the problem is we don't have peace in
burkina faso i hope the military didn't
just come to take power they need to
bring back civilians so they can go back
to their work and defend the country the
army has suffered several defeats
against armed groups linked to al-qaeda
and isil they appear to be gaining
ground forcing millions to flee towards
the capital
soldiers seized power on monday by
attacking the president's motorcade the
troops blame president jake mccabe and
his civilian government for military
defeats and increasing insecurity
the president announced his resignation
in a handwritten note it's not known
where he is though french president
emmanuel macron told reporters tuesday
that he's been informed cabaret is in
good health the eu un and west african
regional organization ecowas are urging
the president's immediate release
they're calling on the soldiers who
mutunir to return to their barracks
my appeal
is for the armies of these countries to
assume their professional role of armies
to protect their countries and
re-establish the democratic institutions
just in the past year there have been
coups in chad sudan
mali
and guinea
this is the latest coup in a region
marked by military takeovers while this
is a setback to democracy some see the
military as able to succeed where
civilians have failed in bringing back
security in a region marked by violence
despite the 14 000 u.n peacekeepers in
neighboring mali as well as 5 000 eu and
french soldiers in the region the sahel
is facing unprecedented attacks and
losses
burkina faso was spared until 2015 when
a popular uprising ended the 27-year
rule of former soldier bless compower
that was seen as the beginning of unrest
while some now celebrate the coup others
fear a return to the past this is an
abrupt end to the democracy so many here
had fought for
nicholas hawk al-jazeera dakar